in physics the equation for momentum is
this p equals MV so if you've got a
certain mass moving at a certain
velocity it's got a momentum equal to
the mass times the velocity like any
equation you can draw this as a graph I
have chosen the axes to be momentum and
the velocity and the mass gives the
gradient or slope of the line now let's
say we want to work out what the area
under the graph is this is simply the
area of a triangle half the base times
the height and by the way this is true
no matter what the gradient is so the
area is 1/2 times P times V now we can
substitute in the original equation for
P because P equals MV so that gives the
area to be 1/2 times M times V times V
or 1/2 MV squared now you may be
familiar with this equation already
it's the kinetic energy of a moving body
and the mathematics we just did shows
how these two equations are related to
each other and in physics we call this a
derivation a derivation is basically how
you invent new physics you take the
knowledge that you already have and you
combine it in a new way to come up with
a description of something new and up to
university level derivations involve two
bits of mathematics the first is algebra
in the second is calculus algebra is
basically taking equations rearranging
them or putting them together kind of
like when we substituted p equals MV and
the example before hand calculus
involves two parts integration and
differentiation integration is when
you're finding the areas underneath
curves and differentiation is when
you're finding the gradients of curves
and the job of calculus is basically to
describe how certain things change when
other things change and this happens all
the time in physics so calculus is an
incredibly useful mathematical tool now
we didn't actually do any calculus in my
example because the graph is a straight
line which basically means it's easy
enough to use simple geometry to find
the area in calculating the gradient of
a straight line is simple it's just the
height divided by the width of the
triangle which in my example is the mass
M
things get more difficult when you've
got an equation that's got a curved line
like the plot of kinetic energy that
we've derived it's a curved line because
it's got a V squared in it now you can't
just use a simple triangle to find the
error in gradient now you need to use
integration and differentiation now I
don't have time to teach you all of
calculus in this video but I'll give you
a brief description of the way it works
the idea behind integration is that you
start by approximating the area under a
plot with a series of rectangles so we
can write that each area is 1/2 MV
squared which gives the height times a
small width which we'll call Delta V and
the total area is the sum of all of
these rectangles the trick to
integration is that as you reduce the
width of these rectangles to be smaller
and smaller this approximated area gets
more and more precise and becomes
perfect when the width of the rectangles
gets infinitely small then we rewrite
this sum as an integral which looks like
this if we do this integration we come
up with this equation and this is
already kind of interesting because as
physicist we don't have a name that
describes the quantity that we've just
found so we're already sort of in the
wilderness of physics a physicists
description of this would be the
integral of kinetic energy with respect
to velocity but seeing as we've
discovered it we can call it whatever we
want so we could call it like super
kinetic energy or something and that's
basically what happens in physics when
physicists get to a new concept they've
got the job of describing it which is
why physics is sort of got so many weird
words in it but there's nothing special
it's just people naming stuff there's
nothing mysterious about it
differentiation is sort of the opposite
to integration here you approximate the
gradient with tiny little triangles at
each point so we would write that the
gradient is a delta half MV squared
divided by Delta V again the
approximation becomes perfect when these
triangles are infinitely small and then
you write
a differential equation which looks like
this the solution to this equation is MV
which is basically back to where we were
at the beginning of the video so
differentiation is a kind of inverse or
opposite process to integration that
just gives you a flavor of calculus but
if you want to find out more there's a
really good playlist on calculus on the
channel three blue one Brown we can get
up here I really recommend it goes into
way more detail and in fact the whole
channel I love it's so good so calculus
is normally taught as kind of an
abstract set of mathematical rules but
to a physicist it's kind of the bread
and butter of what we do day to day you
know like a plumber has got a wrench a
physicist has got calculus when you
learn physics in school you're given a
bunch of equations and you have to
memorize them and you have to apply them
in different ways
but you're never really told where those
equations come from which is
understandable you don't have time when
you're in school and it's kind of like a
next level understanding thing but when
I was at University and I learned
calculus and then I learnt the
derivation of all of those physics
equations it was a really satisfying
thing to learn because it was the first
time where I really understood kind of
why those equations existed where they
came from and also how they related to
each other and then when I started being
being able to apply calculus to come up
with my own equations that was
incredibly cool because it's like you're
you're a frickin physics wizard or
something and so if you ever get the
opportunity to learn calculus I really
recommend it even if just for your own
interest it's a it's definitely
applicable and if you're learning
calculus and you don't really know what
the point is learning something that
gives you the ability to derive new
physics is a very good reason as you
mentioned that algebra and calculus
aren't the end to the mathematical tools
that physicists used to derive new
physics but they definitely form a
foundation which then you can build upon
later or add on different things like
matrix algebra vectors and tensors
depending on what path of physics you go
into you'll need different kinds of
mathematics if you're interested in
learning more about derivations in
physics and how to apply those to novel
situations I recommend checking out the
sponsor of this video brilliant dog it's
a website where you actively solve
problems that are broken down into
trunks and you're encouraged to think
carefully through each section and then
bring them all together to solve the
problem in the end and the idea is to
build up sort of intuition by seeing how
the different parts are related to each
other that then you can apply that
knowledge in novel situations more
easily rather than just memorizing
equations where that's harder to do so
if that sounds interesting check out
brilliant org slash do s link is also in
the description below it and as an added
bonus the first 200 people to sign up we
can get a 20% discount off the annual
premium membership which unlocks all of
their content so check that out and
thanks for watching this video sorry
about the delay from the last one I've
been busy with Professor a stroked-out
stuff we just released a new book and
I've also been writing the next book but
there'll be at least one more video this
month I've got a whole load lined up